francis russe se poursuit en ukraine
notamment à kharkiv ou encore lougansk
le dirigeant tchétchène ramzan kadirov
affirme que sa milice a pris la mairie
de marioupol cette ville portuaire
stratégique mais de son côté l'armée
ukrainienne elle assure que marioupol
n'est pas encore tombé si le risque
d'encerclement de la ville du sud de
l'ukraine nicolas yves a pu être
repoussée pour l'instant l'armée russe
multiplie ses frappes où l'on retrouve
tout de suite julie dingle of notre
envoyé spécial quelle est la situation
actuellement à micola yves
écouter voyez à la ville est toujours
largement bouclé par de nombreux
checkpoints et depuis ce matin on nous
sommes arrivés nous entendons des
détonations très fréquentes soit bien il
s'agit de la défense anti aérienne soit
de tirs à l'armé lourde qui se situe
donc en banlieue de la ville de nicolet
yves carré bien les ukrainiens disent
avoir réussi à repousser l'offensive
russe en banlieue de la ville dans
direction de kherson ancêtres carson
cette ville qui a été prise par l'armée
russe donc ici pour l'instant les gens
les ukrainiens résiste pas
d'encerclement de la ville mais depuis
plusieurs jours maintenant à plusieurs
cibles ont été touchées un tous les
jours par exemple lundi nous étions ici
à micola yves en hôtel a été touché un
hôpital psychiatrique une station
essence ce que disent les autorités de
la ville c'est que d'autres
infrastructures en banlieue ont
également été touchés sans donner
davantage de précisions et pour
l'instant eh bien nicolas yves résiste
elle a même reçu de la part du président
zelensky le statut de ville héros et les
habitants ici veulent croire et bien que
mais le mycologue continuera à résister
c'est aussi ce que nous disent les
habitants d'odessa avec lesquels nous
avons pu parler ces derniers jours que
vous dis à la population comment arrive
t elle à survivre
écoutez ce matin quand nous avons pris
la route entre desai nicolas yves nous
avons pu voir des convois de bus qui
quittaient la ville de nicolet yves
selon les autorités de la ville cent
vingt personnes auraient quitté la ville
ce matin c'est ce que nous avions pu
constater également l'indiquent lorsque
nous étions sur place donc des personnes
cherchent encore à quitter la ville du
fait notamment de ses bombardements dans
le centre ville dont je vous parlais à
l'instant qui ont eu lieu lundi à mais
ceux qui restent et bien ceux qui
restent s'accrochent à cet espoir et
notamment à la fierté de ses soldats
craignant qu'ils continuent à résister
certain temps même d'avoir une vie
presque normale je vais vous donner une
anecdote qui en dit long ce matin nous
étions dans le centre ville de nicolet
yves nous avons croisé un jeune couple
qui sortait de la mairie qui venait de
se marier qui eux et bien souhaité
rester dans leur ville et qui nous est à
quel point ils étaient fiers de leurs
soldats une vieille dame de 60 ans me
disait eh bien écoutez moi je veux
croire que nos soldats vont continuer à
résister je suis très fier qu'ils aient
réussi à repousser l'offensive russe
mais bien sûr beaucoup d'angoissé
également parce que les sirènes
résonnent sans cesse dans la ville parce
que le les bombardements sont très
audible ils font vibrer vibrer le sol
donc beaucoup d'angoissé de la part de
cette population qui doit se réfugier
régulièrement dans les abris mais qui
veulent s'accrocher à cette résistance
dont je vous parlais à l'instant merci
beaucoup gelid une galoche merci à vous
pour toutes vos précisions